so the results are basically in for the
2020 united states presidential election
as well as how close the polls got it
and they were a disaster
keep watching and we'll break it down
i'm richard and this is richard undata
so a few weeks ago i did a video on why
i thought the polls
posters and poll analysts were all
basically incorrect
and how the election was probably a lot
closer than conventional
wisdom made it out to be that video
encouraged all kinds of very
spirited comments but there was a lot of
good discussion there all around and
there were several requests for me to
make a follow-up video
well the results are in now and what i
will say is
i made a prediction kind of just for fun
at the end of my last video
about how i expected trump was actually
narrowly going to eke it out
needless to say that didn't happen but
having said all
that we do have a series of polling
misses to look at now
and i think there's a lot to learn from
this whether you're a data scientist or
whether you're just
somebody who's a political junkie now in
this video i'm going to talk about why
as a data scientist myself who likes to
think he knows a little bit about the
underlying political domain
why exactly i thought the polls were
wrong because
yes my approach to that certainly wasn't
data driven
at least in any strict sense but it was
inspired by the way that i look at data
and models in the real world
and then naturally i'll also talk about
how i over correct it
and the assumptions that i personally
made which were incorrect too
and now that we can also sort of monday
morning quarterback the whole situation
i'll talk about some of the factors that
polling might have missed this time
around
and how we might want to be thinking
about this problem in the future
the other thing that i'll say though is
this will probably be the last video
that i make on this topic
because once again my channel name is
richard on data
and not richard on politics there's a
reason for that
before i get into all this just some
usual asks number one
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and hit the notification bell so
youtube notifies you whenever i upload a
video
then take just half a second to smash
the like button
because that really does help my content
reach a larger audience
and lastly in the description of this
video i'll have a link to my patreon
account
so if you guys would be willing to
support me over there it would be
massively appreciated
now without further ado let's get
started so let's actually start with a
disclaimer which is that
well there are things like recounts and
lawsuits and things like that which
are happening in various states it's
happened
in the past that things like that tip
the scale by like a few hundred
maybe a thousand votes here and there
but it's
very unlikely that you're going to see
any kind of significant change
from where the results stand today and
where the results are
is that biden is at 306 electoral votes
trump is at 232 electoral votes
and the margins in many of these states
were incredibly close
here's arizona which is a traditionally
red state that broke for biden this time
by around
0.3 percent or about 10 000 votes
then this is georgia another state that
hasn't gone blue
since 1992 biden also carried it by
about 0.3 percent or around 14 000 votes
and then here's wisconsin this is a
state that trump flipped in 2016.
now biden took it back this time but by
a margin of about
0.6 percent or 20 000 votes
there seemed to be consensus for a long
time that this election was going to be
a very easy bite and win
biden was way ahead in the polls the
polls were a lot better than they were
in 2016
because they realize now that college
education
versus not is a very important factor
that explains
voting behavior and so while those
people were a lot harder to reach
you could just wait for college
education and it would fix the polling
issues
so how'd they do well they were worse
than they were in 2016.
here's a summary that nate silver put
out on twitter on this
so the polling errors included
approximately trump plus
8 in wisconsin trump plus seven in iowa
trump plus six in florida trump plus
five in michigan
trump plus five in texas and trump plus
five in ohio
and that's just the presidential race
the senate polling errors were even
worse
a lot worse to be fair those are 538
polling averages
now if you go over to real clear
politics and look at their polling
averages
those are a little bit closer but again
these are
averages though which means there are
individual polls which
really didn't age well such as this
a-plus poll from abc news and washington
post
which said that trump was up by 17
points
in the state of wisconsin so let me be
blunt for a minute and put it this way
suppose you or i we're a data scientist
and we're doing survey methodology and
polling for some client
i don't want to say that we get fired
for things like this because that's
probably a bit of an exaggeration
but at the very least the clients that
we were working for
would lose a lot of trust in us and
frankly stop using our work
and yes while it may be true the final
prediction was correct in many of these
places
as little as 0.6 points or more in
polling error would have led to a
completely
dramatically different outcome and so
there are
very open questions about what does this
look like in future presidential races
or even in our current senate races so i
really don't want to let
narrow victories in some of these states
obscure the broader polling misses here
now i made some assumptions about how
various states were going to go
myself which turned out not to be true
so i'm not letting myself off the hook
for this one either
but i did get one thing right which was
guessing that trump was going to
outperform the polls
so why exactly did i make guesses the
way that i did
well it kind of came about through the
same thought process that i would use
for evaluating a real-life statistical
or ml model
and there were three parts to it first
of all is looking at the raw data
which in this context the closest analog
to that
is the polls themselves invariably if
you have bad data
you're going to make a bad model or
you're going to make a bad forecast
every single time and quite frankly when
there's a poll out there that's saying
that a state
that voted for somebody one year and
then swings against the same person
four years later by 18 points in a
polarized
environment i'm gonna be really
skeptical about that because that
really doesn't make a lot of sense
secondly when you look at models and
forecasts
it is really good to take some cases
here and there
look at the forecast predictions that
are coming out and see if they look
reasonable and when i see things like
texas at a 40
chance for biden or things like alaska
and south carolina
in play when they weren't four years ago
i'm gonna have a little bit of
skepticism about that like that
might very well be true but i'm going to
be skeptical and take a second look at
it
but the biggest thing of all to me was
the early voting data
now i understand for established
forecasters it's not
exactly straightforward how to
incorporate this
but i look at this the way i do any kind
of model
which is when i get new data it can be
the best gift
in the world now you could look at a
state like florida that tracks party
registration
and see that there was only a gap of 140
000 votes or so between registered
democrats and republicans
this is from target smart now we knew at
the time
that election day votes would favor
republicans pretty heavily
in part due to differing sentiments
between parties
on mail and voting and the virus and i
thought based on historical precedent
and what the correlation has generally
looked like in the past
that a win in florida would translate to
wins in arizona
and georgia and maybe even pennsylvania
as well
obviously that turned out not to be true
but i do stand by the idea that if you
have
this much new information you would be a
fool not to use it
one of the theories that i threw out
there was that there's some fraction of
the population that was planning to vote
for trump but
wasn't going to tell that to pollsters
aka the shy trump voter effect
now is this a thing well i think it
almost certainly is
and there are good arguments both for
and against the notion that it goes
beyond
trump himself it might have even
extended to republicans
in general during this cycle because you
had
multiple senate republicans who ran way
ahead of their polls
even more so than trump did and this
might have even extended
also to candidates like democratic
senator bernie sanders
and with him there's a case to be made
he's polarizing in his own way
but there are multiple counts of him
dramatically over
performing primary polls it's also a
fair counterpoint
that there were some races that were
kind of off in 2018
but not nearly as much so as in 2016 and
2020
so there is some credence to the idea
that weird stuff happens when trump is
on the ballot
i tend to think it goes a little bit
beyond trump but we may just have to
wait a few cycles to see what happens
at the end of the day response bias and
social desirability bias
do exist in many different phenomena and
i do think it's a little bit myopic to
at least not consider them a little bit
there's a detailed article by political
science professor eric kaufman that came
out a few days after the election
and he pondered this a little bit and he
came up with the hypothesis
that yes the shy trump voter does exist
in particular it's in college educated
whites
particularly females in particular part
of the crux of his argument is that
actually education level was not the
super important predictor that pollsters
seemed to think it was when they looked
back on 2016
but in fact that feelings on things like
illegal immigration
explained a huge proportion of variation
in the trump versus clinton support
in a way that the college education
level doesn't
so really you'd have to wait on things
like attitude and psychology
and these aren't exactly easy things to
do and he also cites a study going all
the way back to 2010
that found social desirability massively
influenced
expressed sentiment on immigration
specifically that the share of white
americans willing to endorse
zero new immigration jumped from 39
to 60 percent when the question was
concealed inside of a list
this is a pretty interesting theory and
it's worth looking at this within the
context of another specific part of the
polling phenomenon
and that's that when some of these polls
looked at white voters
in general some of them actually got
white voters without college degrees
pretty close to perfect actually but
where they did get it wildly wrong
was with white voters with college
degrees
as in wrong by like 26 to 31 points
so if you do have a shy trump voter
effect it's probably in there somewhere
to be clear
this definitely does not tell the whole
story
and actually one other item that i think
is worth paying a lot of attention to
is location now just to introduce this
idea
i'd like to look at a poll from the new
york times in siena
and a great piece that was done on it by
journalist nate cohn
and to give credit to him and to that
organization they are
very transparent about the way that they
conduct their polls
and specifically i want to look at the
rust belt here because
the poles got that wrong in 2016 and in
2020
and it is at this point anyway one of
the most decisive regions of the country
they conducted a poll where actually
they purposely over
sampled people who voted for trump in
2016
and they wanted to get an idea of if
people were switching
in what direction they were going now
i'm gonna try to paint a picture of what
i think the biggest issue here is
and try to make it clear even for those
of you who don't
live in these states or in the us in
general even
now once again in this poll there are
more people who voted for trump in 2016
than those who voted for clinton overall
now i think
one big standout here that you can
pretty easily see
is that red and blue are generally
relatively evenly distributed
geographically throughout this map
however you can look at this map of
where these geographical locations went
in 2020
and frankly this actually is extremely
similar to what it looked like in 2016
and to some extent even 2012
and you'll see that the blue tends to be
concentrated in pockets
particularly in densely populated or
more urban areas
while the red is more spread out in a
larger number of
much smaller more sparsely populated
areas those are typically the more rural
areas
so if i can go back to nate cohn's
analysis here
one thing that catches my eye is the
fact that a lot of the democrats
they sampled seem to come from
republican heavy areas
and the exact same thing vice versa now
it happens all the time that a
geographical area
or region shifts left or right over time
as the conditions and the people there
change
but still certainly in the short term at
least
where our region has been in the past is
some indicator of where it's going to be
in the future
people in various regions and
communities are typically going to be
driven by similar economic factors like
what types of businesses are in that
area
and probably by some degree of cultural
factors as well
and these things just typically don't
change overnight
and to be entirely fair this is just one
poll
and i'm pinpointing one specific issue
with it
but i do think that it illustrates a
broader point
and also you might be thinking just like
i did
would spread of the virus that's
happening in that area
affect how it voted and the answer to
that is
it's a lot more complicated than you
might think but
probably not so the virus and various
metrics like new cases and
hospitalizations
were on the rise at the time the
election occurred even when early
mail-in votes started to come
in and it's not exactly a secret that
trump's approval rating on handling of
this
issue has not been very high and in
particular
it's actually decreased by about 10
points
since the issue really began here in the
us around march
but this analysis from edison research
which was reported in vox
found that actually many people perceive
there to be a dichotomy
between the pandemic and its resulting
economic fallout
and that people's views on this were
highly polarized across partisan lines
and similarly there wasn't a super clear
relationship between the new
cases per million at least at the state
level and where its vote broke
my two cents on this are that this issue
almost definitely damaged trump
electorally
but it is incredibly difficult to
estimate exactly how much
and where exactly and overall i have to
say that my biggest takeaway is that
it's well known these polls control for
factors like party affiliation
age race and to some extent gender
which have in the past anyway been well
known at predicting how one is going to
vote
recently they're doing more to
incorporate college education level as
well
but there are a huge number of factors
out there that can probably explain how
people vote location is one that i made
a point on in this video
that i think could potentially be huge
and
should probably be handled in a more
nuanced way
rather than rural versus suburban versus
urban
there's views on particular specific
issues like the immigration issue i
pointed out earlier
maybe there's things like type of job is
it blue collar versus white collar
what's the religious affiliation what's
the income level
there are all these things out there
which some polling organizations
probably control for
more so than others granted i certainly
don't know what all those different
things
are but i do really think at the end of
the day
the same features that we used in the
past to explain variation in voting
behavior
aren't working quite as well now and we
need to look at different features going
forward
then once we figure out what those
features actually are
the next step is figuring out how to
actually measure these things
appropriately
which could be a challenge in its own
right so who knows how accurate polls
pollsters and poll analysts are going to
be in the future in particular
while we have a constantly changing
world around us but i do have a strong
suspicion
that this is going to go over just like
any other complex data science problem
that knowing how to attack the problem
and make models better
is primarily going to be driven by
domain knowledge
that is a better understanding of the
country and the people
in it than it's going to be from
tweaking models and algorithms
what do you guys think why do you think
that the 2020 polls were off
and then do you think that the polls are
going to improve or that they're going
to continue to worsen
leave your comments down below as always
try to be civil about it
thanks for watching this video and if
you enjoyed it please consider sharing
this video and smashing the like button
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data